it's lunch money time to all of you all
in yes joy
now you're uh uh uh co-host for this
segment and then you're out of here
i'm chopped delivered all right
let's go what's the first topic um just
really quickly nobody tell him that we
actually keep it at 73 in the house
okay so
so mortgage rates just hit their highest
level since 2009 and home prices are
continuing to experience double-digit
gains now nearly all of the major
housing markets in the us are less
affordable than they have been
historically it's the worst for home
affordability since 2006
no it's the worst home affordability
ever it's pretty much uh the way to look
at it they are saying that because of uh
the mortgages but home affordability is
a complex topic because it's not just
about the mortgage rates uh it's also
about the price of the home the average
new home in america now cost more than
five hundred thousand dollars new home
average five hundred thousand dollars
first time in history
broke over that milestone the average
across the country five hundred thousand
dollars for a new home
jumped over that milestone second number
is the average home in america if i
remember my numbers correctly i'm not a
mathematician i'm not einstein but i do
read the internet is over three hundred
thousand dollars again
jumping over that milestone as well now
the price of the homes are going up that
was cool everyone was chill if you owned
a home you're like hey i'm getting rich
if you didn't own a home but you're
looking for a home you're like no
problem i'll go to the bank the bank
will go ahead and give me really cheap
capital you could get an interest rate
somewhere in two two and a half three
percent that was yesterday yesterday's
price is not today's price though
today's price mortgages are over five
percent
now that is the highest since 2006 2007
2008 and so ultimately when they talk
about affordability you can't just look
at mortgage rates which yes it is bad
because now the mortgage rates for the
most part over five percent because the
fed's going to continue to hike interest
rates tomorrow probably a 50 basis point
height there but it's also the home
price themselves have been skyrocketing
higher so you have skyrocketing prices
you have an under supply you have high
demand because people want to move out
of cities because of remote work you
don't have cheap capital anymore it's
like uh housing armageddon literally you
can't find a home if you want one and if
you do still need a home you're gonna
have to go either outside of where you
want or you have to pay more than you
want that's not a good situation to be
in that is not a good situation okay
let's move on airbnb is going all in on
the live anywhere work anywhere
philosophy that much of the business
world has been forced to adopt even
though there's a ton
of companies still saying
no you got to come back to the office
losers why is airbnb doing this and
they're saying that it doesn't matter
where you live
your pay will not change because i think
that's critical
well there's a couple of pieces here so
first of all if you have a job where it
doesn't require you to go back in the
office and your company is mandating you
to go back in the office then uh you
probably need to find a new job because
they don't care about you the second
thing is i know a lot of companies that
say our company specifically wants to be
in the office the employees want to be
here they're energized they're more
focused we get more done we're going
after a very important mission and
therefore by being together we can go
and we can accomplish that that ends up
being a way better pitch than you must
come here or we will fire you and so i
think that it goes back to this idea of
uh when it comes to leadership there's
two types of leadership there's
authoritative leadership which means i
am your boss i am in charge of you you
do what i say or there's influential
leadership which is hey we all are going
to go do this together and where i'm
going to influence you to do something
that i want to do because you're going
to want to do it as well i think that
too many companies are taking the
authoritative standpoint this is the
goldman sachs etc of the world who are
saying you have to come back in the
office you don't come back in the office
we're gonna fire people and half the
staff is just like nah we ain't coming
back we're gonna fire 50 of the company
not gonna do that so what ends up being
better is somebody like an airbnb where
they say look you can work anywhere you
want including you could still work next
to one of our offices and go into the
office the influential component ends up
being really important it goes back to
this idea also colton sakamoto was on
the show yesterday and he talked about
this idea that
in some way the city you live in may not
be as important as the latitude that
you're on kind of the time zone so if
you're a plus or minus three hours from
a certain time zone you're good but if
all of a sudden you say to your boss in
i don't know new york or in chicago or
l.a y'all move to the other side of the
world and be hour time difference
that might not work you may have to have
some sort of synchronous communication
with your team so i think it's much more
about time zones now and then the
companies that have an important mission
and want to influence people to be in
the office just say hey if you want to
accomplish this mission if it really
means something to you come into the
office why not do you have a live
anywhere work anywhere policy with me
can i can i live at home or wait not
live at home work at home
don't answer that
god i got evicted real quick
can i work that's called negotiating
against yourself i didn't even say
anything just negotiated against herself
uh no look there's plenty of people that
we work with on a daily basis that we
say look i don't care where you live but
obviously uh i have to physically come
here every single day so that we can do
this right there's certain people who
have to be here so that we can do this
but i think part of it is we all signed
up for it we made a joint decision like
okay we're gonna go do this every single
day but then there's other people that
we work with who uh there's one person
who literally uh travels all the time
like great but their job is very
different they have a different uh kind
of role responsibility and doesn't
require them to be in a physical office
every day right so i think also the
other piece of this is not teams that
are binary it's not 100 of people in the
office 100 of people work remotely what
you're going to end up finding is um for
example i think this is okay to say but
if not uh here's some free alpha eight
sleep i'm pretty sure most of the team
ends up working from different cities
and ends up working uh remotely but
their hardware team the engineers who
are literally dealing with the hardware
they're all together in new york city
and so that's a perfect example where
like it'd be pretty hard to remotely run
the manufacturing or the the hardware of
that business right but if you simply
are doing sales or marketing or
operations whatever you can do that from
anywhere in the world yeah and sometimes
like being in a different time zone is
beneficial when i was working at fortune
and i was writing term sheet this
newsletter and i would go to bulgaria it
was seven hours ahead so like i would
send this newsletter at 6am and
everybody was like what are you doing i
was like got seven hours on you guys
okay
moving on andreessen horowitz the
legendary vc firm venture capital firm
um is announcing a 500 million dollar
investment in indian startups
specifically they have earmarked 500
million to back indian startups
a lot of them are crypto actually um
what are what do we think about this and
why india why now why
a16z i'm long technology
i am long india he loves india love it i
went everyone already knows this story i
went i visited india i was there for two
weeks i went all over the country bombay
i went to uh jaipur
i went to goa i went everywhere all
throughout the whole country i
absolutely loved the place but not only
do i love it from a geographic
standpoint and the people i met etc but
i had the pleasure of meeting tons and
tons of entrepreneurs and one of the
things that's beautiful about the
country of india is the internet
penetration has exploded the mobile
phone penetration has exploded inside of
the united states we have taken the
american dream we've exported it
internationally we've taken all of the
learnings and the kind of knowledge
advantage that silicon valley had and
we've open sourced that via blogs and
podcasts and uh various things like that
we then also on top of that have
literally aspirationally through
instagram and twitter and tick tock etc
show people what's possible through
entrepreneurship startups and investing
and so if all of a sudden you take what
was so special about silicon valley in
the united states you export that
globally you open up access you reduce
friction and you literally say i gave a
speech to or talk whatever you want to
call it uh to a um
a whole bunch of product managers in
india and i said for the first time in
history a kid sitting in their bedroom
in india with an internet connection can
change the world with a couple lines of
code that was never possible before and
so the second you do that well there's a
billion plus people yeah you got a
billion people and by the way the dirty
secret was tons of american companies
had already been outsourcing some of
their tech work to india over time now
all of a sudden they say look we're not
gonna just work for you we're gonna
build our own [ __ ] and when they start
to do that i think it's gonna be really
really special uh and so i'm very very
long india uh you and i both you don't
know this but uh actually i think you do
know this uh we're lps in a fund that is
focused uh one of their focuses is on
crypto uh in india and so i think that
ultimately i'm an lp
that's right uh i think over time what's
gonna end up happening is uh more and
more people are gonna recognize it does
not matter where you live geography wise
uh and if you have an internet
connection you can code game on it's
awesome like right now i'm working on
this project and i was telling anthony
that i'm working with somebody in london
and i have only ever heard his voice i
have no idea what he looks like i have
no idea how old he is he could be 35 he
could be 85 i don't know but he does
great work and i'm like this is so cool
that we can do this you know why do you
say he
because i heard his voice
and his name is chris
hey
let's just keep going let's go
hold on i just like hold on i just made
a lot of assumptions here oh your boy is
just out there tossing some grenades go
ahead christina
i don't care i don't make any judgments
vice i call everyone they
vice media
the digital company that was once valued
at 5.7 billion dollars can you believe
that has hired bankers to seek a sale it
is unclear if they're getting interest
i'm guessing somebody at the company
freaking
leaked this
do we know what the revenue is does it
say no
but vice was fire vice was the counter
culture media source that the world
needed they were willing to do anything
and everything if there was a story they
were gonna go find it they went into
conflict zones they went to the local
bakery any cool story anywhere in the
world vice was on it
and the reason why
was because shane
and i forget the other uh founder's name
they were in charge and they just said
put the foot to the gas and go and they
empowered all of these people that they
were hiring all these young people to
just go tell the stories and then vice
fell victim to two things in my opinion
the first is they tried to
professionalize they tried to say what
got us here can't get us there and they
got they lost they lost the grit yeah
they got greedy they said oh we want to
be like the new york times we want to be
like this and they got rid of all of the
things that got them there they lost
talent they ended up uh straying from
their strategy exception that was the
first mistake so the second that you
have a product that everyone loves the
comments are lighting up everyone's like
damn vice was awesome
but the second they strayed from that
strategy they started to lose
credibility with the audience that's
that was strike one then two they laid
over it with the buzzfeed occasion
of media you have to understand it's
hard to make money in media no doing
what vice i i'm not saying it's it's
the right thing i'm just saying if you
want to make money you got to produce a
ton of content you got to cater to the
readers like you can't you could be
short-term optimized or you could play
the long game they were playing the long
game they built a rabid fan base they
used to release documentaries i'd
stopped my whole life to go watch the
documentary i remember watching some of
these where literally uh i think it was
kaj larson was
in a fighter jet in nigeria
flying over while they're literally
shooting at people i was like this is
rawest content in the world someone said
they went from badass vice to way too
nice yeah facts and so then the second
thing that happened is when they started
to play the the buzzfeed game of how do
we have the clickbait headlines all that
they started to lose credibility lose
credibility lose credibility and the
difference was they started to look at
the financial pressures of the short
term and they said we have to worry
about making money and what they should
have done in hindsight again armchair
quarterback here but what they should
have done is they should have said hey
20 years from now we want to still be
here what should we do keep doing what
we're doing and just let it organically
grow now the problem is the more money
you raise the harder it is to do that
but that's what they should have done
they couldn't do it though because they
took on money they started talking about
going public started doing all this
crazy stuff and they got put in a corner
and when you raise money from investors
you're kind of bound to going public
selling exiting somehow sure unless
you've got good investors
yeah the investors in spacex they just
chilling hey we've been holding this for
20 years
elon do your thing the investors in
spacex thing they're going to mars in
eight years okay
um next
okay this is a wild one ready yeah so i
see plane weddings so what is this
so this couple
decided they were like serious they were
like oh my god like we should get
married and they're like we're going to
hop on a flight to go to vegas and get
married in vegas except what happened
was that their like connection was
delayed or something so then we went on
southwest airlines and
no no no no no no airlines is the ones
that they said so southwest tweeted this
and they said come sunday the couple
arrived to dfw from okc just to learn
their connection to lis was cancelled
that's las vegas
but that's when their bad luck ended
chris another passenger oh my god this
is long okay anyway it happened it's so
they get married on the plane they got
weird on the plane but imagine imagine
telling your kids yo you me and your mom
got married on a southwest flight i
would i would quit my parents i would
just walk away y'all stupid she like
walked down the aisle like in the middle
through the people and there happened to
be an ordained minister yeah oh just
shockingly southwest was like
and harrison ordained me but people
don't know that is that we kind of did
that what no
no no no no no we did not get married on
a plane i don't do southwest at all i
don't play that game with those people
american airlines shout out the best
airline in the world uh the whole thing
here
i want to make it clear if they're happy
i'm happy if they're happy if this is
what they want to do do you want to tell
people who is our ordained my brother
john
john married john john
he got a online uh uh minister
uh certificate years ago and he had
never used i say i got it i got a job
for you yeah and he uh he did it so he
he could have technically done a plain
wedding he could have but he wouldn't do
that to those people if you get married
on southwest airlines that is a signal
that we probably should be uh worried
about your decision making no yes i
think it's cool you get written about in
today
what does it call them do you want to
know do you want to know why that's a
bad thing why because that's the problem
with society is people are more worried
about can i do something so stupid that
people will write about it on the
internet rather than say i love my wife
or i love my husband i want to get
married because i want to have a lasting
relationship that's what i think they
wanted to do and then people of course
filmed it you know how planes are oh my
god somebody gets out of their seat
people pull out their phone like are we
gonna see a fight are we gonna see drama
am i gonna go viral i have flown with
you multiple times in the last couple of
weeks and i've never seen you play your
phone no matter how many people walk up
and down the eye i know because i'm not
a drama seeker
you
on the other hand
no i'm watching a movie i watched
american gangster on the flight the
other day like i have no interest
whatsoever and what anyone's doing as
long as you don't have a bomb a gun or a
knife i'm cool with you on the plane one
time we were on a plane and these two
people i thought they were gonna get in
a fight but like i was just like
creeping not pulling out my phone the
man in front of us pulled out his like
cell phone in 1987. flipped it out and
just started i was like what are you
doing he was ready to go viral world
star
unfortunately beforehand
that old man couldn't have sent he
continued not using his text messages
but he about to get a wild viral video
on his flip phone
all right what's up with the last one
yes johnny jets is a minister okay
um so so we have asked lunch money time
thank you guys for submitting questions
nobody actually followed my directions
and going to the lunch money video and
posting a question there so this one is
from
did i just yell at the people yeah oh
god i'm sorry stop calling them the
people
my friends
okay
but i'm not like let's go what's the
question communisty hey friends okay
mark oh god oh no
mark
hyper hebert
okay
he asked besides not sending your
children to summer camp or public school
at this point what would be your ideal
educational path for your children
synthesis homeschool or any other
specific program that you could share
with us maybe a broader question what is
the future of education go ahead you
answer first then i'll answer okay so i
have a dilemma like i agree that you've
got a lot of dilemmas the public school
system isn't the best even though i went
through it it's not the best
but
um how else do you like socialize your
kids homeschooling i've known quite a
few kids that were homeschooled and i'm
not sure but some of them are okay but
how do you get the social aspect from
the school if you don't send your kids
to traditional school
your kid don't need to go to school
no there are kids for literally
centuries that didn't go to school they
were fine
they didn't go to public school in the
way that the school is dedicated today
the public school system right now is
absolutely asinine they treat them like
they're prisoners they literally have
them walk down the hallway not talk like
this
walk in a straight line sit down and
then they say to him you are a
seven-year-old little boy
a seven-year-old little boy got more
energy than all of tesla's supercharger
network just put in a little
seven-year-old boy's body they can just
shower they're like shut up sit down
don't talk and just listen and that
seven-year-old boy the whole time you
know he's doing it in his head he's
sitting there like
and then they're like oh you got energy
no you have adhd here now take these
pills now do this now dude it's like yo
leave the kids alone how about this what
happened to your childhood how about
this idea
let the kids just run wild they're gonna
be okay
literally just let them run wild send
them outside and say hey you see this
big ass fence we put here around this
land y'all can't leave the fence i will
but you could do whatever you want for
the next three hours including you could
fight each other you could build things
you could play games you do whatever you
want because that's what's gonna happen
in life when you come back we'll deal
with that whatever happens i will say so
i spent first and second grade in
bulgaria right so when i was there we
had like they gave us way too much
freedom like
for a lunch we had our lunch break we
could leave the school
go home and eat or go to the store i
don't know what you would do and then
come back for class i was seven years
old that's in bulgaria in america you
can't go to the bathroom without getting
a pass they literally make you get a
pass to go to the bathroom so when i got
here in atlanta georgia public school
system um
they were like you gotta walk down the
hall in the street line i was like what
are we doing i was so much more mature
and then we got to the cafeteria and
they served me a corn dog which a
question why are you serving
corn dogs to kids for lunch at school
this is what this is what the american
education system does is they tell kids
literally in all seriousness they tell
kids go sit down do everything against
what you're naturally inclined to do be
curious expend your energy all this
stuff then they just medicate the [ __ ]
out of them with uh all the adhd
medicine etc then they feed them like
[ __ ] at lunch uh kid true oh that's fine
they feed you badly uh poorly at lunch
and then if all of that's not good
enough
then they go and they tell your parents
you're a bad kid
how many teachers around america are
like oh i gotta have the parent teacher
conference my dad used to go to that
stuff my mom used to go to that they'd
be telling them we were wild they were
like your son is so poorly behaved and
my parents would be like what'd he do
and they're like he talked during class
and my parents would be like well maybe
y'all should let them talk to her in
class and we're out of time because he
talked through the timer yes i gotta
have a parent they're medicating the
kids leave the kids alone leave those
kids alone isn't that a song
it's about to be a song leave those kids
alone what is it called
pink floyd leave those kids alone that's
going to be the new uh new theory around
here leave those kids alone all right
all right you got any last words for the
people before we kick you out of here be
kind to your friends that's that's a
good thing to do
comrades